première ville nouvelle à avoir reçu le
label villes et pays d'art et d'histoire
50 ans niveau possède un patrimoine
urbain architectural exceptionnel réuni
son site historique des espaces naturels
des pères de l'architecturé et près de
80 oeuvres d'art public pour le
découvrir sous toutes les coutures avec
la base de loisirs l'office de tourisme
et le musée de la ville nous vous
proposons nos meilleurs plans cet été
avec des dizaines d'activités estivales
c'est tout de suite revient vire
en fait style à la base de loisirs guidé
par l'équipe de l'office de tourisme aux
quatre coins de l'agglomération ou en
toute autonomie grâce à la carte du
patrimoine interactive conçue par le
musée de la ville profitez de l'été pour
découvrir saint quentin en yvelines et
profiter des nombreuses activités
proposées sur le territoire première
étape l'office de tourisme de saint
quentin qui sera ouvert tout l'été et
qui vous a concocté un programme de
choix à l'affice de touristes sont bien
sûr le but c'est vraiment de montrer
tout ce qui est possible de faire sur le
territoire toute l'année et bien entendu
pendant la période estivale c'est encore
mieux parce qu'il ya des événements
spécifiques met en place pour pour l'été
par exemple à l'office de tourisme on
organise des balades avec l'association
ville verte qui est une association
d'éducation à l'environnement et qui
propose des balades guidées dans le parc
des sources de la bière sur des samedis
et des mercredis du mois de juillet et
août vous aurez toutes les informations
agents d'adp sur notre mini-site une
offre qui s'ajoutent à un programme de
balades déjà conséquent là où il y en a
5 supplémentaires qui font l'objet d'une
nouvelle collection donc là on est plus
sur un format un peu plus ludique un peu
plus animé et qui fera aussi l'objet
d'un ebook
en partenariat avec td fils d'ailleurs
il va apparaître dans le numéro du petit
quentin juillet-août en supplément mais
après il sera disponible aussi à
l'office de tourisme et en
téléchargement il y en a une par exemple
qui s'appelle port royal des champs par
la forêt donc on part d'ici et on fait
un tour jusqu'à port royal et on revient
par la foire est donc est assez
sympathique puisqu'il s'agit de de se
promener avec les enfants en bas âge de
parc en parc
des
c'est un beau livre qui est traité sous
une forme d'agenda parce que c'est moi
par mois qu'on peut effectivement
découvrir le territoire les activités
proposées les événements proposés les
lieux proposés dans cet agenda sont
praticable je dirais quasiment toute
l'année il est vraiment une offre très
intéressante qui sera plus plutôt
détaillé dans notre mini-site n'oublions
pas effectivement qui se passe aussi des
choses autour de autour du bassin du
centre commercial donc là ce sont les
médiathèque la médiathèque du canal et
le musée de la ville qui se regroupent
pour animer l'espace donc autour de soi
sein entre le mois de juillet mois
d'août avec notamment les célèbres
ferrasse des médiathèques mais peu sur
des chaises ont profité de la lecture et
puis le musée de la ville qui propose
aussi des ateliers pendant moitié et au
musée de la ville justement vous propose
aussi des promenades réaliser vous même
mais sous un aspect un peu plus
patrimoniale la carte interactive du
patrimoine elle n'existait déjà d'abord
en version papier c'est le premier
document qui est l'hymne label villes et
pays d'art et d'histoire
et puis depuis 2010 elle est déclinée en
version interactive ce qui est très
pratique puisque à partir du plan de
ville en fête de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines vous allez sur
le site de l'amélioration
le surplus en ville interactive et là
vous avez un anglais partent du
patrimoine avec 15 points de couleur qui
apparaît et donc classés par couleur
vous avez pas très noir contemporain
patrimoine ancien patrimoine naturel ça
vous permet en fait de d'avoir d'avoir
une vue d'ensemble de tous patrimoine du
coup vous pouvez repérer sur le plan de
ville les lieux exacts avec les adresses
où sont positionnés les amoureux d'art
public qui n'a plus de 80 par exemple où
les églises de village la commanderie
templière
pour ensuite éventuellement construire
nos propres balade dalles au musée vous
propose également des promenades
thématiques clés en main pour découvrir
notre patrimoine selon des plans
parcours agrémenté sur place de panneaux
explicatifs l'incident parcours vous
avez aussi un petit flash code qui vous
permet avec votre smartphone et une
application que vous avez téléchargé
préalablement de d'avoir accès à un
audioguide avait avoir accès des images
supplémentaires par rapport à l'oeuvre
que vous pouvez trouver sur le fric donc
des images de la restauration d'autres
d'amener d'artistes et à déclinaison
familiale et ludique de ces plans
parcours des rallyes plus ou moins longs
vous permettront également de découvrir
notre patrimoine seventies ou encore
l'art dans la ville et pour les sportifs
et les amoureux d'activités nature non
nous ne vous avons pas oubliés direction
la base de loisirs qui propose cette
année de nombreuses nouveautés il ya
quoi il ya quoi il ya quoi y'a quoi y'a
quoi à plein plein de nouveautés c'est
lé cas nous l'été
on a déjà on a travaillé sur un
aménagement de l'espace puisqu'on a
remis aux normes plein de jeux pour
enfants dans libre-service donc à la
fois sur le parc est à la fois sur une
nouvelle zone de barbecue après nous
avons la tyrolienne géante qui est
derrière vous en fait 150 m de dénivelé
ou au fur et à mesure en france on veut
briller on se lance et on va terry de
l'autre côté de l'étang de la queue de
détente passe au dessus de l'eau
verture de piscine à vagues à partir du
6 juillet avec à l'intérieur du beach du
beach volley donc on a un espace de
sport de plage nous avons le judo tour
donc une grande opération autour du judo
pour les petits les confirmés autour du
15 15 juillet et puis fin de fin du mois
de juillet nous avons huit sessions où
l'on travaille l'athlétisme ou la deux
avec la fédération d'athlétisme ou des
challenges pareil de la compétition du
loisir découverte de ce sport que
l'athlétisme le village sportif c'est
pareil 29 juillet jusqu'au 30 août donc
c'est de nombreuses activités que je ne
peux pas vous lister tellement tiana
destiné aux 11-17 ans de manière
gratuite il suffit simplement de
réserver auprès de la bad et loisirs
vous êtes un service jeunesse un centre
de loisirs pour les plus de 11 ans et
vous pourrez pratiquer parfois des
activités alors on ouvre cette année de
nouveaux sons de voile mais on le vivre
à terme la milieu de l'été mais avec ses
traditionnelles activités stages stages
sportifs canoë kayak catamaran
entièrement rénové et une ouverture
grand public
on va dire fin juillet et bien sûr avec
le golf national et un golf à la base de
loisirs vous pouvez pratiquer tout l'été
à travers des animations dédiées mais
également avec l'opération citi golfe
qui vous permettra de jouer en ville
et maintenant les actus voix
les noms des bus de ses actus avec une
bonne nouvelle orly n'était jusqu'à
présent desservi que par la ligne de bus
91 06 91 10 ce samedi à partir de la
rentrée cette ligne express sera
renforcée deviendra quotidienne massy et
orly seront accessibles tous les jours
dimanche compris avec un simple ticket t
à 1euro 30 il est temps de parcours
seront diminués bonnes nouvelles
toujours vous ne savez peut-être pas
mais si vous habitez l'une des sept
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
vous pouvez bénéficier de la carte
annuelle offertes par la communauté
d'agglomération pour accéder
gratuitement en voiture à la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
pour l'obtenir rendez vous dans votre
mairie avec la carte grise de votre
véhicule une pièce d'identité et un
justificatif de domicile et on termine
ses actus avec des informations deux
saisons qui vous empêcheront de perdre
du temps ou de vous retrouver face à des
portes closes à partir du 8 juillet le
réseau de médiathèques passe à l'heure
d'été et aménage ses horaires vous les
retrouverez à l'adresse internet qui
s'affiche et vous noterez que vous
pouvez emprunter à volonté tous les
livres dvd cd et journaux de votre choix
pour une durée de six semaines le
bibliobus quant à lui stationnera sur
l'espace était en sable de montigny et
sera ouvert tout l'été de 16h30 à 18h30
des sujets que vous pouvez retrouver
ainsi qu'un article sur l'écrivain en
résidence à la ferme daleba dominique
sampiero et les portraits des capitaines
des équipes de foot féminin de saint
quentin en yvelines dans le prochain
bien vivre celui de cet été alors à très
bientôt
pardon on va leur faire
un article sur les six cas portrait de
pousthomy